hey crazies you've probably seen Atomic
orbitals before
they're those weird looking shapes that
show up near the end of a chemistry
class
the problem is they're always so static
the universe isn't static it's Dynamic
it's all about change Atomic orbitals
are no exception
let me show you the way they were meant
to be seen
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
our first obstacle is going to be that
we we can't actually see any of this at
least not directly
the super tiny wavelengths of visible
light are thousands of times larger than
an atom Optical images just aren't
possible at that scale
the best we can do is a diagram based on
electron microscope data
every one of these spherical lumps is a
gold atom
that makes atoms look like tangible
little balls which they aren't and it
doesn't tell us much about what's
happening inside
I mean with such a simple image there
could be cake in there
spoiler alert it's not cake the cake is
a lie I think it's pretty common
knowledge at this point that atoms are
made of three things
protons neutrons and electrons they're
called subatomic particles for obvious
reasons
based on experiment we know the heavy
protons and neutrons are packed into a
tiny nucleus and the electrons fill a
volume a hundred thousand times larger
the complete collection is what we call
an atom
since electrons fill the vast majority
of the volume of their atom they tend to
control what their atom does
this makes understanding their behavior
extremely important but figuring that
out was a pretty difficult process
historically speaking
to the timeline
we went from floating in a Mist to
orbits to Circular standing waves all of
which were ruled out by experiments by
1926 we were left with only one option
quantum mechanics
which as many of you know borders on
absurdity
quantum mechanics is weird y'all you can
quote me on that
and if we're wrong about it the universe
can only be weirder than we already
think it is
remember we ruled out all the normal
stuff
is this where Atomic orbitals come in
yep let me make something absolutely
clear though electron orbitals are not
orbits like at all like any Quantum
State an orbital is a state of
probability yes really
here's an example of an orbital
brighter spots are where you're more
likely to find an electron and darker
spots are where you're less likely to
find one
but the truth is we don't actually care
that much about where electrons are
position is a pretty pointless property
what do we actually care about then
energy and momentum
conserved properties
in fact Schrodinger's equation is an
energy equation
don't freak out I'm not going through a
full derivation or anything if you want
to see that you'll find it in
excruciating detail in my book
but quantum mechanics is like 90 math if
you want to learn more than just
buzzwords you're going to have to deal
with at least a little math get on board
anyway this is just kinetic energy plus
potential energy equals total energy
that's it that's all this is a Quantum
version of the conservation of energy
half the battle when using this equation
is figuring out what the potential
energy is
in our case it's what holds the
electrons in the atom and its influence
is entirely radial
you can actually see that pretty clearly
in the electron microscope image from
earlier
that's why they look like tiny spheres
because their influence is radial
to take advantage of this Behavior we'll
need one of my favorite tools spherical
coordinates
they're so cool nerd oh shush
rather than three linear labels like X Y
and Z we use a distance from the center
an angle from the vertical and an angle
around the horizontal
since the potential energy only depends
on the distance from the center it can
be separated in our solution to
Schrodinger's equation
it gives us an idea of size where the
angle part gives us an idea of shape
let's focus on the shapes first
they're called the spherical harmonics
notice how they're all oriented along
the same axis
one angle draws a curve and then the
other angle makes it a surface
each one of these shapes goes with a
specific angular momentum it's what we
call orbital angular momentum because
these are orbitals not orbits the axis
they're lined up with is the direction
we're measuring the momentum along
because this is quantum mechanics we're
only allowed to measure along one axis
at a time
it's kind of limited isn't it yeah but
it's actually enough
one number tells us how long this
angular momentum arrow is
the other number tells us its
orientation by projecting the arrow onto
the measurement axis
these two numbers are all you need to
know the shape of the orbital you can
even organize them into a Nifty chart
like this
man I love charts I mean look at this
thing
yes
unfortunately none of those shapes are
probability distributions yet because we
left out the radial part
it's only half the solution
including the radial part turns our
shapes into probabilities
it turns these into these which are
further organized by energy level
these are just probability distributions
brighter spots are where you're more
likely to find an electron darker spots
are where you're less likely to find one
it's a visual of where you might find
something if you looked
we generally don't look though because
we want the position to be uncertain
that way the energy and angular momentum
remain definite for each state
but like I said at the beginning of the
video this all looks pretty static
Atomic orbitals are actually dynamic an
electron can absorb and release photons
which can change that electron's energy
electrons can jump between Quantum
States
based on what I've mentioned so far
you're probably only imagining a simple
fade but it's actually way cooler than
that
quantum mechanics might be weird but but
it's still a set of rules the events
might be probabilistic but the
probabilities are deterministic
and that probability must be conserved
just like energy and momentum
that means you can imagine probability
as if it's a fluid filling all of space
when the distribution changes that
probability has to flow to the new
locations orbital transitions look more
like this
that flow is called a probability
current
kind of cool huh
so what's an atomic orbital a Quantum
state of probability
the angular momentum tells us the shape
the energy fills the volume of that
shape with detail and gives us an idea
of size
brighter spots are where you're more
likely to find an electron darker spots
are where you're less likely to find one
but the probability of finding the
electrons somewhere must be a hundred
percent at all times
Quantum probability must be conserved
when an electron changes Quantum states
that probability has to flow to the new
locations in a kind of probability
current
so in some level maybe the cake isn't a
lie after all
as long as by Cake you mean probability
so what do you think is the cake a lie
let us know how you feel in the comments
Thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
could an AI be alive
well it could eventually become
self-aware at which point we should
respect it as a conscious being but that
doesn't necessarily make it alive
Consciousness in life are two totally
different things anyway thanks for
watching